The ending is one of the most important parts
of any movie, so it's no surprise that directors
have often wavered back and forth on what
tone to end their films on.
Even movies that would eventually become classics
almost had significantly different endings
that were originally planned.
From boxing dramas to Mafia epics, here are
a few movies that almost had much happier
endings.
Rocky Balboa
Whether he wins by knockout or loses by split
decision, Rocky Balboa almost always walks
away from the ring with a smile on his face.
As the man puts it himself:
"It ain't about how hard ya hit.
It's about how hard you can get it and keep
moving forward.
How much you can take and keep moving forward."
At the end of Rocky Balboa, the Italian Stallion
loses in a split decision, but wins the respect
of everyone watching the fight.
However, there's an alternate ending in which
the brawler bests his opponent, walking away
with a razor-thin decision.
"Heavyweight champion, Roockyyyyyyyyy Balboa!"
Is it happier?
Yeah, but it isn't Rocky.
My Best Friend's Wedding
After a series of mishaps and hijinks, Julia
Roberts eventually gives up on romancing her
best friend and spends the last moments of
the movie dancing with another friend instead.
In the original ending of My Best Friend's
Wedding, Roberts finds a potential new boyfriend
at her friend's wedding, but test audiences
were confused by the sudden appearance of
a new beau.
"Hi.
I'm Andy Connelly.
We haven't met."
Test audiences liked Rupert Everett just way
too much, so he was able to make his triumphant
return in the finale.
"You're going to humiliate me, aren't you?"
"Only if I can."
"Just one thing, stay away from-"
Easy Rider
This seminal biker flick follows a bunch of
laid back hippies on a cross-country road
trip right up until an incredibly violent
ending.
Right before the credits roll, we see the
bikers lying dead on the road, with their
motorcycles in flames.
While director Dennis Hopper originally wanted
the bikers to make it out alive, writer Terry
Southern told The Paris Review that he'd convinced
the director that the dark ending was, quote,
"more or less mandatory" for Easy Rider.
"You got a helmet?"
"Oh ho ho, I've got a helmet."
Why?
Southern wanted to write, quote, "an indictment
of blue-collar America, the people [he] thought
were responsible for the Vietnam War."
Message received.
Rogue One: A Star Wars Story
A prequel to A New Hope, Rogue One follows
a group of resistance fighters who are able
to steal the plans for the Death Star by sacrificing
themselves in the process.
However, in one of the early drafts of the
screenplay, the ragtag group actually makes
it out alive.
Director Gareth Edwards explained to the Empire
podcast,
"It was just assumed by us that we couldn't
[kill the cast], and they're not gonna let
us do that."
As it turned out, they actually could, and
the result is one of the best sequences in
Star Wars history.
Chinatown
Working for a mysterious woman named Evelyn
Mulwray, Jake Gittes uncovers a massive fraud
operation in Los Angeles.
Worse, he that the father of Evelyn's child
is actually Noah Cross, Evelyn's twisted father.
It's pretty grim stuff, all capped off by
a showdown in Chinatown where Evelyn is killed
while Cross steals his daughter-granddaughter.
Gittes stands in the middle of the street,
defeated, as a colleague tells him:
"Forget it, Jake.
It's Chinatown."
However, Robert Towne's original screenplay
would have had Gittes and Mulwray murder Cross,
allowing Evelyn and her daughter to finally
escape his grasp.
Director Roman Polanski, in a very dark place
himself due to the recent murder of his wife,
rewrote an ending where evil triumphs over
good, and added the famous line to create
a grim, unforgettable ending.
The Thing
When a shape-shifting alien attacks an Antarctic
research station, the crew must band together
to fight this otherworldly foe that can look
like anyone and anything.
Who's human, and who's a thing?
That's the ultimate question posed by The
Thing's downer of a finale.
The film ends with two men sharing a bottle
of whiskey, freezing to death, and waiting
to see who's really who.
Editor Todd Ramsay was so worried about the
ending that he persuaded Carpenter to film
a backup, just in case they had to make a
change later on.
According to Ramsay:
"Just shoot an ending where we see that he
survives."
"Kurt has been rescued and is sitting in a
small office structure and he's just had a
blood test so we know that he's not infected."
Fortunately, Carpenter stuck to his guns and
The Thing is now recognized as a classic,
largely thanks to its ultra-ambiguous ending.
The Godfather
After rising to the top of the Mafia mountain,
Michael Corleone has truly lost his way, going
so far as to murder his own brother-in-law,
deny it to his wife, and close himself off
from her in the most tragic door slam in cinematic
history.
Believe it or not, director Francis Ford Coppola
actually shot an alternate ending.
In this deleted scene, we see Kay visiting
a church and lighting candles for Michael's
soul, hoping there might be a chance her husband
can be redeemed.
But even though the ending was closer to Mario
Puzo's novel, Coppola realized that he'd already
shot the perfect ending and left it there.
"Don't be afraid Carlo.
Come on, you think I'd make my sister a widow?"
The Fly
David Cronenberg's The Fly follows Seth Brundle,
a brilliant scientist who accidentally merges
his body with a fly.
The movie ends with Brundle completely mutated,
finally killed by his pregnant girlfriend
in a moment of tragic horror.
However, Cronenberg actually considered going
with several other endings; one possible ending
has Veronica drifting off to sleep and dreaming
that her future child will hatch from a chrysalis
and fly away with butterfly wings.
Thankfully, Cronenberg realized that after
the tragic end of Brundle, audiences wouldn't
be happy walking away with visions of butterfly
children, and stuck to his original ending.
"Oh...
That's disgusting."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!